all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we just got our first look at
parker robbins technically we got it
yesterday but we got our first look at
parker robbins aka the hood and i have
as many questions as i do just being
giddy and excited about his character
because i love the hood the hood is one
of these characters of marvel comics
right parker robbins he's one of these
characters in marvel comics where he's
just like a villain of the week who's
always trying his best to be the top guy
but can never quite make it but he
always has like just these insane
moments right just these insane feats
that he's pulled off so for those of us
for perspective about this you give you
guys some examples in the old solo
series of the hood by brian k vaughan
one he basically stole some or at least
stole his red hood and his boots kind of
his iconic outfit he stole that from a
demon that was that just kind of
appeared in the middle of a seance
because him and his cousin john king
thought they were breaking into a
warehouse to steal some magical
artifacts the guy like was obsessed
right like like parker robbins was
obsessed with the idea of becoming a
villain he loved that idea but when he
stole those he didn't realize it at the
time and even we as the reader didn't
know it was something that was
established by brian michael bendis in
his new avengers run that basically
parker robbins was in was imbuing the
power of dormammu it didn't make him
godlike it gave him a kind of passing
knowledge of magic and mysticism most of
his magical abilities derived from the
hood and the boots itself so like the
boots allowed him to walk on air the
hood gave him the ability to go
invisible or to shoot like energy blasts
different things like that right like
resurrecting the dead things along those
lines and a lot of those come from the
actual hood story itself but in new
avengers vol 1 issue number 56 he got
the norn stones from loki the nornstones
are a little finicky right so what they
can do is contingent based on two things
one that the nornstones except the
person that picked them up if parker
robbins had picked up the nornstones and
the nornstones were not receptive to him
they would have just been random pieces
of rock and that would have been it such
as it was when he did take the northern
stones then they allowed him to
basically fulfill his own individual
wishes that's the second caveat of the
nornstones they do not have a definitive
ability right they're not like the
infinity stones which we'll talk about
here in a second because parker robbins
did get the infinity gauntlet at one
point in time that the nornstones
themselves basically grant wish
fulfillment so they will allow the
person to become whatever it is they
wish to become so a really good example
of this is that with parker robbins he
ended up becoming basically like super
rich wildly capable all that kind of
stuff right he was a very very capable
and interesting character contrast to
that you had like thor while he did
become interesting the idea behind
thor's motivation in gaining the
nornstones was to basically defeat the
beings called those who sit above in
shadow who were responsible for the
cycle of ragnarok the death and rebirth
of asgardians seemingly over time it was
hypothesized they were beyonders we
don't know for sure loki really
hypothesized that during the final days
of loki's storyline going into avengers
2 i'm sorry secret wars 2015 but
basically when thor got the nornstones
he became rune king thor he was a
multiversal force it was ridiculous how
overpowered he was it was very temporary
and he died at the end of that story and
then of course ended up coming back
during j michael cerzinski's run but the
thing about this is that parker robbins
has these really cool moments right
following the whole nornstone story arc
and like all the money that he attained
that that went directly into the new
avengers story which was specifically
new avengers vol 4 which was the run
that came before the events of uh
jonathan hickman's avengers in new
avengers run but basically he used his
resources to attain two of the infinity
stones and the way that bendis had
reworked the infinity stones in marvel
comics was that they desire to be
together so by attaining one this led
parker robbins to the others and then
once he attained all the others he
reformed the gauntlet now of course
following that it was taken by iron man
and then he essentially went forward and
was just kind of parker robbins again
and iron man dispersed the stones among
the illuminati who kept them for safe
keeping which explains how it was they
had them at the beginning of hikman's
avengers a new avengers run when the
incursion started the point that i'm
making here is that parker robbins is a
guy who's very very small time right
he's a sealess villain at best but he's
a seedless villain that just kind of
seems to be at the right place at the
right time for a lot of these campaigns
and ends up achieving like these just
insane feats but can never hold on to
the level of power that he has so it's
one of those things where you kind of
feel bad for him right where you're like
man he's really trying so hard he's
trying so hard to be this ridiculously
amazing villain but he just he just
can't quite get there right just can't
quite get to that point so he's one of
those villains that you love to feel bad
for
and as a result of that fans love parker
robbins oh you'll let me say some man
you run up on a person who loves parker
robins and you're like that guy sucks oh
they won't hear a word against them
they'll flip out right i mean they
literally tie their love of parker
robins into their identities right like
if you don't like parker robbins you
don't like me which doesn't really make
any sense to me but the point behind it
is they love his character because he's
interesting or he's really really
fascinating now what role he will play
in the mcu that's the question to ask
here because there's a lot of potential
for a character like him but as we know
with the marvel cinematic universe they
have a lot of potential with their
villains but they usually screw it up
and they kill the villains off it's just
one of the biggest failings of the mcu
that failing is becoming more and more
pronounced and to be honest with you
guys i think that's going to spell the
end of the marvel cinematic universe if
they don't get it together because
heroes are only interesting for so long
villains are really the more interesting
characters in comic books right heroes
are only as interesting as the villains
they fight and so as a result of that
when you look at parker robbins he is
just the total opposite of riri williams
riri williams is not based on magic and
mysticism if the leaks that have gone on
here which i'm surprised we haven't
covered and i feel like we need to if
the leaks that have come out with
regards to the to black panther 2 are in
any form true then instead of riri
williams being a girl who rose to
prominence by way of reverse engineering
stark tech and building her own iron man
suit that instead she'll come to
prominence by way of creating a device
that locates vibranium across the world
outside of wakanda that things are going
to go awry there's going to be some kind
of an explosion some of neymar's people
are going to be killed and that's going
to lead to name with a submariner
basically stepping in and that's how he
gets involved in the movie and that's
how you end up having this sort of
animosity between namor and the
wakandans so there really isn't much in
the way of any iron man involvement what
this does do is it solidifies the
greater role of ruby williams which is
to say she is a being of technology and
logic and so it'd be really interesting
if parker robbins does have magical
abilities in the ruby williams tv show
and they're kind of the opposite of each
other right where he's more magic she's
more technology and those two don't
necessarily mix they kind of do right i
mean thor talked about that in the first
movie when he was talking to jane foster
and saying that jane foster says there's
magic and then she says there's
technology and thor says i come from a
place where basically it's a combination
of both magic and technology that are
merged together to achieve a particular
end or to do particular things right and
so it'd be interesting if parker robbins
represented that sort of opposite to
ruby williams but beyond that i think
parker robbins has a lot of potential in
the marvel cinematic universe because
one of the things that we don't know
much about in the mcu is the nature of
magic itself that's one of the things to
keep in mind we know what we've been
told by the ancient one and we know
we've seen with regards to stephen
strange himself but outside of doctor
strange magic is a hitherto unexplored
concept in the mcu it's still very very
new right i mean doctor strange had the
book of ashanti at one point we don't
know how much of that magic he's
basically retained in terms of what he
saw or what he absorbed from the book
itself you know before it was destroyed
his magical powers could be amplified we
have agatha harkness and her side of
things we've seen just how powerful a
magical being can become with regards to
the scarlet witch there's still the
being of cathode that hasn't been
explored and has only been referenced
there's all kinds of stuff there right
so one of the things to know is that
when it comes to magic and marvel comics
that you do have an entire magical
organization there right like you
literally have bars places where only
those of magical power can access you've
got places like the center's market
which is like a flea market for magic
where you sell your soul or at least
parts of your soul to attain varying
levels of power or magical artifacts or
different things like that there's a
whole other side to this that has never
been explored so while i wouldn't go as
far as to say that i think parker
robbins is a character that's going to
have direct ties to dormammu that his
hood is somehow originating from
dormammu along with his boots and that
he's maybe a host for dormammu and
that's how he's going to come back i
don't think that will happen i do think
that parker robbins could be our gateway
to sort of the quote unquote ground
level elements of magic right where like
characters like luke cage on netflix or
daredevil or jessica jones or that
garbage ass iron fist show where those
were our sort of link to like ground
level superheroes fighting ground level
crime more of a tangible and relatable
hero that parker robbins could be that
for magic i don't know if that's going
to be the case i really think it could
be and i think it'd be awesome if it was
but my biggest fear is the same fear
that has always been when it comes to
interesting villains introduced into the
mcu then at the end of the ruby williams
tv show they're going to kill parker
robbins off and then they're going to
have another villain that's going to
come in again it's just kind of an
all-important lesson that the marvel
cinematic universe just hasn't learned
and it's the biggest failing of the mcu
up to this point which is killing their
villains as opposed to recognizing the
villains are almost always more
interesting than the heroes but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you guys for
watching let me know what you think in
the comments section about parker
robbins and i will catch you all later
peace